as an OB GYN who specializes in Volvo
vaginal disorders I hear a lot of myths
about vaginal yeast infections and the
one that just won't go away is that
they're linked to too much sugar in your
diet
on the surface the idea sounds plausible
after all sugar is a food source not
just for us but also for yeast and
bacteria so if we eat more sugar we're
feeding the yeast and there are studies
that show yeast infections are more
common in people with diabetes who can
have higher levels of sugar in their
blood but the truth is the sugar
consumption yeast connection is a myth
for most perpetuated both by
well-meaning but ill-informed Healthcare
professionals as well as purveyors of
snake oil you know the ones who want to
sell you cleanses diets and books
designed to help you get rid of all the
yeast the first thing you need to know
is that yeast is normally found in the
vagina at some point in a given year one
study estimates that 70 of people will
have yeast in their vagina just hanging
out in the microbiome and causing no
symptoms and secondly sugar is normally
found in the vagina after all that's
what also feeds the good bacteria it's
the overgrowth of this yeast that's
already there that produces symptoms and
results in what we call a yeast
infection one theory for the sugar yeast
connection is that the source of the
yeast is actually in the gut and that a
high sugar diet feeds this yeast which
makes it overgrow and then it gets into
the vagina but there's no credible data
to support this another theory is that
eating more sugar causes sugar levels in
the vagina to rise thus feeding the
yeast but it doesn't and yes someone
actually studied this researchers gave
people some with a history of vaginal
yeast infections and others without a
drink containing a lot of sugar or
glucose their blood and vaginal sugar
levels were measured before and after
the drink they found that the sugar
levels in the vaginal secretions didn't
change for either group but what about
diabetes now we know diabetes is
associated with an increased risk of
vaginal yeast infections but the actual
reason why isn't known while very
elevated glucose levels might be part of
it it seems the immune system and other
factors may also be playing a role there
is a newer class of diabetes medications
that causes people to dump a lot of
sugar into their urine as a way to lower
blood sugar the massive amounts of sugar
in the urine can cause yeast infections
on the vulva as the vulva is being
bathed in levels of sugar it didn't
evolve to handle but unless you have
diabetes there is no link between eating
sugar and yeast infections so ignore the
so-called influencers it's fine to enjoy
a slice of cake now and then and
definitely
skip the cleanses